c'est demain tout près de six ans après
les attentats du 13 novembre 2015 ap
eric va commencer un procès qui va
assurément marqué l'histoire un procès
qui devrait durer neuf mois il va se
tenir dans une salle d'audience spéciale
qui a été construite pour cet événement
ces attentats tantin au bataclan au
stade de france des terrasses aussi ça
fait 131 morts et plus de 400 blessés
mon prochain invité il l'a vécu ici
retrouver otages des terroristes au
bataclan il s'appelle stéphane tout
l'orient bonsoir messieurs tout les
liens
bonsoir on est à moins de 24 heures du
début de ce procès on vous retrouve ce
soir dans quel état d'esprit
assez impatient que le procès démarre
parce que on a beau s'y préparer
je reste persuadé que le vivre va être
assez différent de tout ce qu'on a pu
imaginer se retrouver dans la même salle
que les accusés
voir à côté de certains des accusés qui
comparaissent libres ce sera forcément
quelque chose de particulier
racontez nous votre histoire vous étiez
au bataclan donc ce fameux soir alors
les terroristes sont entrés à
l'intérieur
qu'est ce qui s'est passé par l'achète
comment vous vous êtes retrouvé ratage
alors en fait les terroristes sont
entrés par le hall du bataclan
de mon côté moi j'étais au balcon parce
que j'étais un peu fatigué et que
c'était une fin de semaine et donc ils
ont commencé à tirer au rez-de-chaussée
et ensuite ils sont montés à l'étagé et
du coup nous on savait on était
plusieurs dans ce cas là on ne savait
pas trop vers où aller et à un moment
donné on s'est retrouvé nez à nez avec
deux des terroristes qui étaient montés
à l'étagé et qui nous ont rassemblés en
disant venez par ici on ne va pas vous
tuer
ils ont ensuite fait leur discours en
disant qu'ils étaient il faisait partie
de l'état islamique et qu' il était là
pour venger leurs familles qui
recevaient des bombes de la part de la
coalition en irak et en syrie
à ce moment là un des trois terroristes
s'est fait exploser sur la scène du
bataclan et c'est ce qui a amené les
deux autres qui étaient donc à côté de
nous à nous demander de bouger et donc
on s'est retrouvé 11 otages dans un
petit couloir qui est au dessus de la
scène et donc on est resté à peu près
deux heures et demie avec ces deux
terroristes qui était juste derrière
nous à peu près 80 cm
jusqu'à l'assaut de la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention
une brigade d'élite de la police
parisienne
essayé à ce moment là que on a été donc
exfiltré par les forces de police et
sans aucun des otages blessé
physiquement de manière grave
par contre effectivement depuis six ans
on a eu le temps de soigner nos
toute la partie tout l'impact
psychologique que l'on a pu vivre après
cette soirée mémorable
ces otages impliquée dans un fait
c'était bord et s'appliquer dans votre
prise d'otages est ce qu'ils vont en
être présent demain lors de ce procès
n'ont en l'occurence les trois
terroristes qui étaient
ils faisaient partie du commando
spécifiquement pour le bataclan soit
ce sont faits ont fait exploser leurs
ceintures explosives
soit ont été abattus par les forces de
police en l'occurrence les personnes qui
seront dans le box des accusés il reste
celui qui est présenté comme le
principal accusé à savoir salle abdeslam
qui est le dernier membre du commando
qui on ne sait pas encore pourquoi ne
s'est pas fait exploser ce soir là
l'ensemble des autres accusés sont des
personnes qui ont fourni des planques
des véhicules des armes qui ont
confectionné les ceintures d'explosifs
et pour certains qui ont revendiqué les
attentats ou qui ont
supposément commandité les attentats une
partie de ces personnes est supposée
morte et avoir été abattu en irak ou en
syrie vous avez vu la mort de près vous
l'avez vu autour de vous vous avez vous
cru mourir avez vous cru que vous
n'alliez pas en sortir pendant un moment
dans cette prise d'otage
la réponse est clairement oui dès le
moment où j'ai vu sur le balcon les deux
terroristes arrivés vers moi et même
s'ils disaient regroupez vous par ici on
va pas vous tuer à partir de ce moment
là pour moi il était clair que j'étais
mort à plus ou moins longue échéance et
je ne savais pas si cette mort allait
intervenir dans l'heure qui allait
suivre ou dans les trois jours qui
allait suivre en fonction de l'évolution
de cette prise d'otages vous êtes
capable d'en parler aujourd'hui avec
avec beaucoup de calme avec pratiquement
certaine sérénité comment vous avez fait
comment vous avez fait pour vous sortir
de cet univers morbide
alors forcément j'ai été bien entouré
par mes proches par ma compagne par ma
famille à mes amis dont certains
habitent au québec
et puis j'ai également
fait une thérapie avec une psychologue
qui a duré un an et ce qui je pense a
été très important également c'est le
fait que assez rapidement j'ai souhaité
et j'ai réussi à retrouver les otages
avec lesquels j'ai passé ces deux heures
et demie on se voit très fréquemment on
a lié une amitié qui est très très
profondes ce qui est plutôt rare à mon
âge et puis de manière un peu plus large
je fais également partie d'une
association qui s'appelle life for
parisse et qui regroupe beaucoup de
victimes des terrasses et du bataclan on
se voit régulièrement et il en ressort
une entraide une solidarité une
bienveillance qui est assez incroyable
et c'est aussi pour ça que même si je la
prends pas beaucoup de choses de ce
procès parce que je doute que les
accusés parle et répondent aux questions
que chacun se pose
malgré tout je sais qu'il va y avoir
vraiment une une communauté une
solidarité et qu'on va tous être là pour
réaffirmer le fait que les terroristes
n'ont pas gagné que l'on continue à
aller au concert on continue à aller
boire des verres en terrasse et donc
pour nous et pour la mémoire de ceux qui
sont morts ce soir là il est très
important d'être là et de participer à
ce procès vous êtes capable de retourner
un spectacle de retourner voir un verre
sur un terrain sans avoir une arrière
pensée sans avoir une crème qui vous
habite
alors comme comme vous avez dit ça fait
maintenant presque six ans
il est évident que au départ j'avais des
appréhensions je sais de l'hyper
vigilance
mais je me suis forcée au bout de trois
semaines à peu prêt à retourner voir des
spectacles des concerts de rock parce
que c'est vraiment ça qui
constitue mon grand plaisir et donc
autant les premières fois dès que je
rentrais dans la salle de spectacle je
rappellerai je repérais les issues de
secours maintenant avec le temps ça
s'est un peu atténuée et puis on va pas
se mentir le fait qu' il y ait moins
d'attentats terroristes que la fréquence
diminue même si dans les années qui ont
suivi 2015 il ya quand même beaucoup
d'attentes à un peu partout dans le
monde mais on on peut dire qu'en ce
moment il y en a un peu moins ou en tout
cas on parle un peu moins de ceux qui
surviennent en irak en afghanistan ou au
yémen
mais du coup on est un peu moins
impactées et ça nous permet aussi
de devenir un petit peu plus serein
rapport à la situation vraiment
félicitations pour votre résilience pour
votre courage lors de mai vous replonger
dans ses souvenirs qui vont probablement
être avait faim raison du procès on
saute beaucoup d'énergie pour passer au
travers de sa mrc pour les témoignages
je vous en prie merci beaucoup merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici rdi